j'en ai vu d'autres questions oui alors
une question qui nous provient de
facebook
thérèse gabriel quartier qui dit on vit
dans une province où l'électricité est
abondante et provient d'une ressource
renouvelable l'eau alors que comment se
fait-il que nous ne soyons pas inonder
de bornes de recharge pour voitures
électriques
alors peut être qu'on peut élargir aussi
au sujet du transport évidemment avec
des nouveaux véhicules qui ne sont
offerts ça se passe que ça commence et
c'est commencer encore là il ya des
municipalités qui ont été des modèles
qui ont initié le mouvement avec
évidemment aidé au québec qui a un
programme visant à inviter les
municipalités à se constituer une banque
de borg est en fait une fois que les
municipalités sont engagés dans ce
processus là et que les bornes sont en
place mais il ya une publicité qui est
faite à l'échelle nationale et qui nous
disent si vous allez dans telle ville il
ya tel ou tel ou tel job et ça ça s'en
vient c'est commencer ça fait partie je
regarde chez nous ça fait partie des
deux derniers budgets on a dit on va en
installer quelques-unes par année et
lentement mais sûrement on aura des
on attend un circuit de bosses tu vas
être utilitaire à la fois aux gens de
chez nous mais aux gens qui viennent
d'ailleurs celui chez nous par exemple
initier les l'institution qu'a initié
sur chez nous c'est le collège de ses
jets dans sa perspective doit être plus
vert alors ils ont installé des bornes
les arts dont deux cd étudiants qui
utilisent maintenant c'est sebag non et
c'est assez extraordinaire saison c'est
eux qui nous ont pointé du doigt disait
faites votre fête va pas maintenant mais
c'est parti il y en a de plus en plus
même encore la petite municipalité
grandes municipalités autour des hôtels
de ville
il ya des bornes maintenant qu'ils sont
installés et lentement mais sûrement
on est en train de se bâtir un circuit
intéressant